last story this is really funny there's
a reason you should not you should look
but not touch okay when you are at the
Museum especially when it comes to Art
this is what is left of one of Jeff
kuhn's famous balloon dog sculptures
yeah it was on display at an art fair in
Miami last week and artist says he saw a
woman
what attack the sculpture with her
finger what knocking it to the ground
and we not balloon folks it's not made
out of balloons it's actually porcelain
look at the guy with like a five dollar
just like plastic
dog was valued at 42 000 there was no
you break it you buy a policy in place
but the piece was insured the person in
charge of the display until the New York
Times that the number of blue balloon
dog sculptures has now shrunk to 798. so
Nate you can get one for your crib
because I know you got the room making
it slightly more valuable no they kicked
her out expeditiously uh Vlad thank you
so much